Sandrine Rousseau n'était pas venu les
poches vides sur le plateau LCI le son
est d'origine quand l'intérêt général
sera pas la porte et quand on aime son
pays je crois que voilà une partie
j'étais déjà cassé avant
c'est pas le bruit d'un siège qui tombe
qui a une une armoire normande entière
avec des casseroles et des assiettes qui
est tombé sur le plateau de Mexique
personne et surtout pas moi ne peut
rester sourd à cette revendication de
justice sociale et de rénovation de
notre vie démocratique puis il avance et
tente de donner un nouveau départ à son
second quinquennat un an après sa
réélection nous avons devant nous 100
jours
d'apaisement d'unité
d'ambition et d'action au service de la
France on dirait qu'il veut se battre
mais en silence vous savez comme quand
on est en voiture et qu'on
s'en embrouille à travers la vitre
pourquoi vous êtes là ce soir
[Musique]
ou dire pour apaiser votre colère ta
gueule
[Musique]
ah ben ouais ben il y a quoi ce qu'elle
met hein
431 millions c'est notre chiffre du jour
et c'est le nombre d'habitants en Inde
qui est devenu le pays le plus peuplé de
la planète et passe donc devant la Chine
avec même plus d'habitants que
l'ensemble du continent européen un
indien sur deux est âgé de moins de 28
ans depuis 1947 date de son indépendance
l'Inde a vu c'est un peu population
augmentée d'un milliard de personnes les
chiffres c'est une chose l'orthographe
c'est une tu présentes mes excuses une
fois que je peux me venger sur un
banquier
[Musique]
non mais ils nous font souffrir les
banquiers vous êtes
d'accords
le concept d'intelligence artificielle
que là c'est bien d'ailleurs au cerveau
du président de la République il dit les
choses telles qu'il voudrait qu'elle
soit il sait tout mais il ne comprend
rien il regarde mais il ne voit pas il
écoute mais il n'entend plus quand il
met en ligne tchat j'ai pété qui permet
à n'importe qui de discuter gratuitement
avec une intelligence artificielle c'est
le Big Bang aussi génial que dangereux
l'outil fait flipper tout le monde lui
le premier
[Musique]
lors d'un concours organisé par Sony le
photographe allemand Boris et daxen a
remporté un prix grâce à ce clichés
il refuse finalement la récompense et
avoue qu'il n'a jamais pris cette photo
puisqu'elle a été générée par
l'intelligence artificielle l'objectif
de l'artiste était d'ouvrir le débat sur
les images créées par l'IA qui sont
maintenant d'un réalisme à s'y méprendre
mission réussie puisque Sony songe
maintenant à organiser un concours pour
les créations réalisées à l'aide de
l'intelligence artificielle quand
j'entends dire cette bêtise c'est le
vaccin qui a éradiqué le covid les pays
qui sont pas vaccinés et il est parti le
covid en Afrique mais laissez-moi
terminer au lieu de parler tout le temps
lors en Afrique en Afrique comment vous
expliquer que le covid existe plus vous
le cactifer ils ont pas vaccinés
notamment à cause du climat merci d'être
venu
[Rires]
des réseaux très organisés qui
rivalisent d'ingéniosité pour installer
sans cesse de nouveaux points de dire
une journée ou pour une saison en une
journée allez 120000 euros
c'était pour un une animation pour une
convention non
un célèbre un célèbre groupe de d'agent
immobilier à Monaco c'était très très
bien payé sur le premier
âgé de 17 ans les policiers trouvent une
liasse de billets plus de 2000 euros
[Musique]
et après il fallait il fallait être
gentil avec tous les invités
[Rires]
champion de la bafouille
elle vous passe le bonjour à côté de moi
non mais je vous en veux pour tout à
l'heure
quand tu es là et puis cette action coup
de poing tiens écouté au championnat du
monde de billards snooker comme on dit
en Angleterre ou des militants écolos on
grimpé sur les tables hier et verser de
la poudre orangée
tu peux faction stupéfaction voilà la
réaction du public qui est pas habitué à
ce milieu dans l'entrée feutrée pas un
bruit habituellement ce sont les mêmes
écologistes
on pourrait remettre vos chaussures mais
on va gérer ça on va vous entendre
la maison des maternelles vous attendez
quelques instants et puis on se retrouve
demain avec des chaussures cette fois
bonne journée
[Musique]